In regards to histamines, one of my breast cancer drivers is histamine. I avoid histamine
foods as much as possible. I understand that leftovers grow histamines. I wouldn't
say they grow them, but the longer food, the older food is the greater amount of histamines
it is. Does it happen with all leftovers or just that are even foods that are not histamine
foods? Good question. Well, there's some histamines in pretty much everything. So the older the food
is, even if it's a very low histamine food, it'll have more, but still probably not anything to
be concerned about. So if it's a low histamine food and it's a leftover, I would not be concerned
with it at all. Don't don't even consider that. Don't even take that into your account.
In this scheme, an example, I cut up some great cabbage, purple cabbage, blah blah blah in
advance for a week. Is it growing histamines? I would say probably not. So you can look at histamine,
you can google food histamine lists and you can see 10 lists and they can have a great difference
between those 10 lists. The reason is that if you sent these things to a lab to test for histamines,
it would be all over the board. So let's say I had sauerkraut and then we had another thing
of sauerkraut. We sent it to the lab. Different readings depends on the age of the sauerkraut and
sauerkraut has histamines in it and everything. So it just could be very all over the board. So
that's why we say what I've written about histamines and my videos about histamines, it's not
about eliminated histamines. It's about just reducing them. So, okay, nuts have histamines. That
means you shouldn't have any nuts. No, but maybe don't have just a bowl full of nuts for a snack.
You know, so strawberries have histamines in it. The grapes don't have as many histamines. So
maybe just don't have a bowl full of strawberries. Doesn't mean you can't throw some strawberries
and you're smoothie. You're just trying to reduce your amount of histamines without going crazy
about it. For the Navarro Test, the acetone says to have 100% acetone, mine says it has 100%
acetone that lists one other ingredient listed. No, you can still use this acetone for the Navarro
Test. Now, I will say I will ask your opinion on whether the Euro Navarro Test is accepted because
the last I heard they're not accepted the Navarro Test. So if they're now accepted the Navarro Test,
that would be a great thing. So let us know if they're accepted the Navarro Test.